uh whether it's Benghazi whether it's
Hillary's emails whether it's uh we know
the Hillary's email stuff is was there
like that's that's not even we don't
know if Hillary Clinton gave a command
to delete stuff that should have been
deleted to impede an investigation we
don't know that information which is
what the charge would have been for sure
sure we know that she had a server with
35 000 emails on it we know that their
staff smashed hammers we know that um
one of our staffers I guess he went on
Reddit and he said how can I purge
emails with someone's name on it or
something like that sure and like I
think didn't he get charged or something
I don't know I think it was granted
immunity in exchange for information
yeah yeah that's crazy right I remember
when that happened like some dude on
Reddit found the account and they were
like I think this guy worked sure but
the crime that we were looking for was
whether Hillary Clinton ordered
classified emails to be deleted it
doesn't seem like I was we spent a whole
lot of time talking about that and for
all the complaining that we do about a
judge indicting Trump or intelligence
agencies interfering in elections Comey
coming out of making the statements that
he did about Hillary Clinton were not
only unprecedented but also potentially
election altering too so